I'm firing it up our favorite game
totally fair
I still have an updated my profile
picture great that's a good picture how
do I do
okay how do I do this you have to go
through you plates yeah I did mine on my
xbox 360 somehow all right I'll do it
it's a process no no I got it
it's right here I have to log in the
website why would I need to go here
aside all about to eat [ __ ] you know it
just it's a too small Samoa everyone's
blessed with the normal size our
enlarged file some of us just have small
fast nobody it's nothing to be ashamed
of okay all right I'm not I'm glad I'm
good good good that's good that's good
that's good when do is my picture update
here never I think you have to restart
your game or restart you play or restart
steam you've there something I'll
restart the game oh yeah please it's
fine here I come
oh I came here ready mix the game audio
on the floor right it's awesome
it's so cool okay Barbara why am I alone
in this lobby right now I'm still
opening it's stuck loading Barbara's
fault Barbara this is in Barbara's fault
got it go it's in loading out no network
connection hey toss me another one those
invites you're not I can't even see you
like this am I not online because I
tried to update my profile pic type
let's see if marks did Marcus at you
another invite and I'm not I got a
little bit all of a sudden you appeared
online I'm getting out of you know I got
online as soon as I exited the game yeah
this is Barbara with your own self
Barbara Barbara [ __ ] you yes I agree
[Laughter]
glow boxer but it's gonna be yeah look
lovely global person nice place
Global Hawk thank you skin me no no you
didn't
this just reveals the hand yeah oh
that's sweet +4 hmm that's not so good
for mark that's not so good not so good
for you yeah it's re figured well that's
not so good for Glo except for he had
two of these did the most depressing
start to no possible Globox you better
play a nine do it [ __ ] you oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you yellow [ __ ] the P oh oh dear
dear me oh goodness I would challenge I
don't trust him it's fine oh well sorry
wait wait what's a good color for you to
punish him red all right that's
punishment
oh yeah they've gained three more cards
well okay
draw some cards bud Barbara's in my chat
talking [ __ ] okay hey gobo whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa let's not let's not do
that
don't do that Oh what the best card in
the deck red we can't see your hand wait
how many you got
- no you had three okay well that's hot
yeah I was tired of the roping you had
red so just playing [ __ ] red and
what's wrong all right fine now don't
try to remember what color Wade had
I believe he has green and yellow good
Bob that's not good I know what you're
gonna do with that I know what you have
that's that color no I don't think you
know mark you don't want to let this
happen buddy yes Bob it's fine I'm mark
that's awkward
that's cool yeah what's cool bud that's
real cool this you're gonna appreciate
this okay well yeah yeah I thought you
would which is why I'm into this now
that's not good that's what you get that
is what you deserve
I scheme so although remember that time
that I schemed it yeah I remember yeah I
do remember that yeah we all remember it
was a good time yeah everybody sorry bud
that's what you give Bob Bob skipping me
yeah I've got a lot of stuff backed up
here what does that copies okay well
that's not what I was going for oh no
man look at all those good cards I got
baby all right let's see what else is in
the store let's all just all right we're
back to start yeah we might as well have
not done anything honestly yeah you know
thank God for you with your Saint
now that sucks all right well really
just gonna get that out of the way are
you sure about that
um tells me he tells me it might have
some grouper sand mmm I think you did I
remember it's okay just somebody reverse
this please do it I want you to do it
how about you have a sweet eight
Oh No aha got you [ __ ] wait who do we
get Oh box got to play there eight Oh
what the [ __ ]
no well that's it work out very well
okay everything is as it should be
that was very clearly glow boxes fall
for jumping in when they shouldn't have
done didn't Bob when sorry and Mark when
trouble I don't also Bob just quit my
Bob quit Bob where you go Barbara came
in well quitting - leaving thank God
I forgot how this game works actually
yeah you just just stick with us and
don't leave that's all right that was
Rayman we never had to play that deck
again that was it okay good good man bye
goddamn it I was like an invite please
he's joining do it yourself on an invite
I'm like a vampire I can't enter the
lobby until I get an invite I sent you
another don't you did where it's in
where the invites go where's the third
one
I don't see you except the third one I
don't see it there's nothing he's
playing the goddamn thing isn't he
no is that recording is this a recording
- no he'll never trust me no I won't I'm
doing the game no I didn't get an invite
I will be very clear I didn't get an
invite you can watch the video
yes I agree no Barbara just give us
Globox again not letting her you'll see
see I don't believe that that right off
the bat okay okay I don't care if I win
my only okay well I won't do anything
this round but man in the future Barbara
over you write about you doing nothing
now dude Pro that's really mean
yeah sure wasn't he did to me too I'm
just gonna how do you have so many cards
it's your [ __ ] hands oh my cards
stupid okay well you got me there you
really I feel like this is all just
marked recording you right let me play
no you [ __ ] you alright alright oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you right
alright you right stop
is that really mark Barbara you can see
right there I see you right there
Barbara whose turn is on left [ __ ]
I love damnit no problem with this hand
isn't there oh yeah I see I see a
fundamental problem over there yeah I
did not a goddamn maybe you have some
red huh no stop it
well yeah well it Otto played good take
that okay enjoy your nine cards what are
you a robot hey I'll give you another
chance
Oh buddy Oh friend o mine
Oh take that Barbara yeah [ __ ] the same
[ __ ] this is the same problem [ __ ] what
color you need Bob mmm I can't do I mean
blue I could do some stuff I guess you
got it buddy sorry
[Music]
good good good is you can make it even
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good Dickens
thank you that's you're really just
giving the game away there huh no one
has read Zoe they're all [ __ ] we're
gonna read it was it your hand
[Laughter]
can I go on the plus Florida Wade yes
and I know what color it should be you
had green I don't believe you oh well I
can take it now I got it god damn it
okay that's all right
just whatever I guess all right well you
know I still have [ __ ] red or goddamn
now we're then we're all these Reds
coming from yeah looks like a lot oh
wait I forgot no you're not fired it up
no I just needed to do that for science
all right do a Barbara do a real good
yeah I got one of those too well give me
your hand Barbara I'm just enjoying
everything about Barbara and she just
are you kidding me hey well I guess I'll
just play that one then that's good okay
that's good that's cool just for me even
a play now and that's good no wait we
play game wait listen wait
No okay well just uh well you could
still do it it's fine it's fine it's
fine you're totally good mark wait
listen dude even more than it looks like
Wow here with presents for you Barbara's
goddamn cards man I got my handbag I
love this hand I'm feeling positive
about this guy's oh wow that's good too
thanks bye ahead and have one side wow
they're making for you good plan Wow
that's a good one what a game guys just
play some threes back-to-back just once
you wanted this deck and you wanted
Barbara this is what you signed up for
hey I'm having a great time don't hello
calm down man it's just a game it's fun
enjoy
the swim it's [ __ ] Barbara wait actually
you wanted this end whoa that's
aggressive it's gonna calm it down a
little bit relax
no it's fine it's good [ __ ]
oh yeah red Barbara what is this [ __ ]
Barbara holy has the best cards as I
always say yellow oh man that's a while
all those threes in there look at that
that's crazy good choice good choice Bob
good choice oh yeah teamwork yellow
again wow man Bert's got the yellow
going on over there
great oh you did nothing
Harvick get out here I don't understand
what's unfair Lee that's that's
aggressive that's key
do I wanna live the life so I'm gonna do
the life good choice am i right that's a
good choice oh dude that's ragga needs a
lot of cards I love it when you laugh
wait cuz I know you're having fun happy
jovial some might say Oh [ __ ] happy as
a [ __ ] lark yeah now it sounds it
sounds good
you're always happiest when you curse I
know that I'm in there getting the
Dickens I'm really giving it oh man I'll
play outplayed oh yay oh alright just a
friendly little 9 here uh-huh okay
change of color barber see you later Han
cool all right
that's a good one good play good play
everybody good color look at that change
[Music]
[Laughter]
Ben my positive attitude just care I
just sailed through that email from
YouTube that my youtube video about [ __ ]
is suitable for all advertisers why no
good thanks manual reviewer that's good
to know
yeah so shit's shit's cool guys hard
shits are cool huh it's cool all good
all good
very good I got one of those oh dude
late on this god am i right everybody
Barbara yeah
what are you doing here come on doctors
just with Barbara come on I didn't have
a choice [ __ ] it seems to be exactly
what she's going to do yellow that's too
rich for me I can't afford yellow stuff
you know how much more expensive yellow
stuff is than other stuff that color
Red's a great cards after you okay
Barbara absolutely did that one this
happy peaceful music [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is a party for ker that's fine by
God my head played so goddamn
beautifully like a [ __ ] violin in the
cello of nights
[ __ ] you wait and you write yeah you
write you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Barbara Barbara you write
Pappas's [ __ ] Barbara's vault am i
but am i right though you're right just
let you win like Bob was playing [ __ ]
game 5 garbage have fun pretty cool yeah
it's fun right I would let you win mark
but I have to play this I'm sorry that's
okay I get it
Barbara is probably gonna give you the
victory though I under oh she's gonna
try come on Barbara you know what color
it needs to be you say no no I see a
number yeah we just
Barbara nope
[Applause]
okay mark mark that was a good hand man
that was a good good yeah oh wow that's
not what I clicked on but okay yeah
listen wait here
I've got a I've got a good hand you can
have it oh you've got some special
guards in the air check that [ __ ] out
man that's correct this [ __ ] [ __ ]
wait do you remember how bad I lost it
trouble you just gotta take the good
with the bad man that's fine I'm fine I
just hate Barbara so you don't sound
fine you sound like you're having
trouble you sound like you're projecting
a lot of your own insecurities on
Barbara and it's yeah definitely oh yeah
come on dr. Phil laid on me like I did
look wait when you feel when you feel
this rage dude to ask yourself Who am I
really mad at I think we all Maura
you're mad at yourself
no just deflection no way do you know
how to be honest you got to be open with
yourself okay Barbara is a card talking
wait you're projecting you're deflecting
you're defending see you at that sign
that's not Barbara's fault that's the
heart why not you because you blame me
for things that Miss book you Barbara do
this I receptor plus for mark property I
also accept your plus for cuz [ __ ]
everything I was gonna do all right
well that's that's kind of positive
that's something wait can you do
anything about this I don't know pay
attention man all right let's watch you
see if you win [ __ ] four [ __ ] you
wait I still feel like you're you're
just you're you're not taking
responsibility for your own actions here
[ __ ] responsible [ __ ] going on I I
just I wanna I'm on your side button you
know I want things to work out for you
but it's is that a blue four so I can't
play my [ __ ] red for God yeah yeah
it's it's a blue for watch out for that
you could just let Barbara win No hey
everybody gets a turn why can't Barbara
win yeah she did two games ago no I
don't remember that oh you're just
feeling you're just so angry right now
mark and I'm not Barbara hey Barbara you
know what to do all right
that's creepy wave you need it I know
calm down you know you know it what do
you got back there way to blues yellow
and a very good plus forward now you're
right yeah you're right I didn't really
you are the recording right you right
you right you right you right
[Laughter]
that thing is hilarious have one of
these things Jesus we'll never have to
talk again do a challenge where we we we
have to pre-record conversations or like
you know phrases and then try and have a
whole stream where we communicate using
only the phrases that's not a good color
way that's a rough that's a dudeson on
it
you know what I could use some more
cards that's what I could use some how
to people just gifted
subs to [ __ ] Barbara holy sweet Jesus
Chet that's just happened oh man all my
wild draw four is they're gonna just get
spread around the entire Earth all right
well let's just get this party started
right away yeah I don't have one of
those okay I appreciate the sentiment
though I thought we were all just gonna
[ __ ] each other right there but I guess
none I mean I was ready for the [ __ ]
I was gonna film the goddamn [ __ ]
sequel sorry Bob I know why you assume
the worst of me I'm I'm here to be your
friend men I'm a collector of cards I'm
here to be your friend he's got blue and
red I'm gonna keep this to you Bob this
is doing one of you next I feel as
though like leave it red so I could give
Bob this card I didn't know I do never
to click that actually I guess switch
this switch this around every barber
gets a call good job yes Barbara please
I could have jumped in but I'm in a
little barber why good play barb good
play
[Music]